[Musique]
chers compatriotes 5 millions de 168
1613 françaises et français m'ont fait
confiance au premier tour de scrutin
ils m'ont ainsi fait l'honneur d'être le
candidat au deuxième tour candidat pour
le changement pour la défense de la
démocratie républicaine la défense de
vos libertés est tout simplement
candidats pour l'honnêteté politique
vous allez fixer votre destin pour cet
antre monsieur pompidou et moi s'engage
un grand débat national
de son issue dépend l'avenir de chacun
d'entre vous en un mot l'avenir de la
france
le choix est simple continuer le passé
monsieur pompidou n'at-il pas été entre
1962 et 1968 premier ministre et il a
effectué six ans de pouvoir
certains ont dit six ans de pouvoir
personnel et moi je propose un
changement politique profond changement
de méthode politique changement
d'orientation de l'état c'est d'ailleurs
ce que veulent les français puisque 53%
d'entre eux se sont prononcés pour le
non au référendum et que le 1er juin 56
% ont confirmé cette volonté
les français veulent que cela change
et c'est pourquoi je n'ai pas envisagé
hu a condamné dix une seconde de me
retirer
d'abord parce que la constitution
prévoit que les deux candidats arrivés
en tête au premier tour se maintiennent
pour le deuxième tour le journal
officiel l'a confirmé ce matin
chers compatriotes si vous m'aidez pour
défendre votre désir de changement pour
défendre le retour nécessaire au
dialogue une gestion plus raisonnable de
l'économie du pays
l'avenir de vos enfants et la justice
sociale la paix du monde par l'europe
unie si vous vous mobilisez à mes côtés
pour défendre ma candidature parler de
moi autour de vous à vos amis à vos
parents la victoire est encore possible
croyez moi qu'importe la pauvreté de mes
moyens et la richesse l'opulence même de
ceux des autres la valeur d'un programme
ou d'un candidat ne se mesure pas au
nombre d' affiches apposées sur les murs
à la peinture répandue sur le sol
en matière électorale la pauvreté c'est
la liberté
chers compatriotes si vous le voulez
vous pourrez avec moi mener une nouvelle
bataille du non celle du non à monsieur
pompidou à quoi voulez abouti à monsieur
pompidou en demandant mon retrait que
voulaient les bons esprits qui m'ont si
longuement demandé de me désister ou de
partir est ce qu'il voulait obtenir pour
monsieur duclos un succès plus important
35 à 40 % des suffrages
est ce qu'ils voulaient éviter de faire
mentir monsieur malraux qui a dit un
jour qu'il n'y avait plus rien en france
entre le gaullisme et le communisme
et bien si mes chers amis il y en a en
france
ce courant national que j'ai incarne
avec vous et qui créent maintenant une
véritable innovation politique pour la
défense de la république
venons en à ce combat monsieur pompidou
a gouverné pendant six ans je vous
disais tout à l'heure la france le
connais bien
pour ma part je n'ai
confiance en sa politique il veut tout
changer dit-il pourquoi n'at-il pas fait
hier quand il était au pouvoir
nous nous voulons d'abord libérer la
république de l'emprise d'un plan et
remette de l'ordre dans l'état
nous voulons près simplement éviter la
colonisation de l'état après tout qui
est responsable des polices parallèles
financée par des ressources inavoués qui
a donné des cartes de policiers à des
truands et qui payent tous ces gens là
jean de sac et de corde qui responsable
des pressions sur la magistrature qui
n'a pas supprimé les juridictions
d'exception et qui a favorisé la
nomination rapide des magistrats qui a
accepté de siéger dans cette juridiction
spéciale en matière de subventions
collectivités locales qui responsables
d'un certain favoritisme
n'at-on pas entendu dans une campagne
est dans la dernière campagne municipale
des candidats pouvoir dire que si on ne
votait pas pour le liste
la ville serait privé et d'équipements
eux dans l'on parle de la rtf lower tf1
formation des guides et opinions de
l'euro fort mais nous en reparlons dans
une autre émission mais également la
mainmise sur l'état des agents de l'état
qui deviennent des agents de propagande
pourquoi ne pas par et non plus de
l'absence de dialogue dans les
assemblées du parlement
les votes bloqués l'administration qui
gouverne à la place du gouvernement et
du parlement
il faudrait à mon sens et c'est notre
devoir libérer aussi les français des
charges écrasantes qui pèsent sur leurs
économies et puise la monnaie et menace
le climat social le plein emploi les
impôts sous la gestion de monsieur
pompidou l'impôt direct a augmenté de 50
% l'impôt indirect de 80% et si on nous
dit aujourd'hui qu'on va dégrevé
un million d'assujettis à l'impôt
général sur le revenu il faut de même
considérer qu'en 1962 il n'y avait que 3
millions de cotisants maintenant il y en
a 10 il en restera au moins millions le
chômage non de chômeurs et les 256
milles en 1962 est un 30 juin 68 2 540
mille ont remarqué ce ne sont des
exemples gens présents très bien d'eau
dans les émissions suivantes
je proposerai les solutions du
redressement par le progrès la sécurité
la france sur huisne par ses dépenses de
prestige et sa puissance industrielle
est en retard quand on regarde à côté de
nous en allemagne ou en italie
non seulement nous prenons du retard
mais nous sommes dépassés dans toutes
les statistiques il faut arracher la
france a cédé gestion makhzen qui
détruit sa vitalité
l'europe est un des moyens par l'europe
la france peut retrouver demain la vraie
voie monsieur convient nous promet le
redressement
rires il promet doux mais je n'ai pas
confiance dans cet ancien ministre qui
r&d de vous voir et qui oublie ses
responsabilités d'autres fois c'est
pourquoi en définitive j'ai maintenu ma
candidature
après on va parler de la gestion parlons
aussi de l'entourage les ultras du
gaullisme et cette majorité unie qui va
de capitan à giscard d'estaing en
passant par sanguinetti foccart debré
ducatel tixier vignancour et duhamel
duhamel qui le combat aujourd'hui après
m'avoir soutenu hier il ya une certaine
démagogie aussi dans les exposés qui
sont faits si je prends le cas des
commerçants et artisans
on leur promet maintenant le salaire
fiscal qu'on leur refuse et hier la
réforme de la tva et de l'assurance
maladie qu'on a fait voter et maintenant
à l'ordre du jour l'agriculteur on leur
promet une amélioration due
revenus de l'exploitation familiale que
ne l'at on fait plutôt les anciens
combattants égalité règlement du
contentieux aux collectivités locales
une meilleure répartition des charges
entre l'état le département et les
communes
mais tout ça a aidé au programme d'hier
et on ne l'a pas fait quant aux
européens ont leur promet l'europe unie
mais pourtant qui est responsable des
crises graves de 63 65 67
chaque voyage en province permet de
connaître des nouvelles promesses
d'autoroute d'équipement de tout genre
mais tout ceci coûte d'argent j'ai pu
chiffrer à près de 2000 milliards
d'anciens francs par an toutes ses
dépenses mais le budget est déjà en
déséquilibre près de 1000 à 12 100
milliards qui paiera tout cela qui en
définitive sinon le pays réglera les
étrennes de monsieur pompidou face à un
candidat qui a oublié sa gestion passée
et qui maintenant fait beaucoup de
promesses
moi je vous ai offert un contrat en 12
points qui a été publiée avant le
premier tour j'affirme vouloir défendre
la volonté les français de restaurer les
libertés et la réconciliation de tous
j'ai vous le savez une conception
nouvelle du rôle de chef de l'état qui
est d'ailleurs celle qui existe dans la
constitution de 1958
le chef de l'état garant arbitre
animateurs car nous ne voulons pas
revoir ce pouvoir arrogant et solitaire
qui nous a mené où nous sommes
confie doux mais chez pompidou invoque
la menace du désordre
l'argument est d'ailleurs assez usé
avant le référendum menaçait et avec
l'aide du gouvernement comme président
de la république intérimaire
l'ordre a été assurée et il n'y a pas eu
de chaos comme je vous l'avais promis
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
la france n'est calme que parce qu'elle
attend une gestion nouvelle
et si l'on attende était frustré il
n'est pas sûr qu'elle conserve tout son
calme car une france paralysée par le
retour au pouvoir d'un clan dominateur
serait une france sans repos il y aurait
risque de désordre dans ce cas lord je
vous la firme n'est valable que lorsqu
il repose sur la justice et il ne peut
se maintenir dans le cas contraire que
par la répression
c'est cette fatalité de la violence
qu'il faut rompre en restaurant la
démocratie et la justice sociale le
dialogue avec toutes les catégories
sociales
il faut se préoccuper du sort des
français du sort des travailleurs qui
paraissent un peu oublié dans tout ça de
leurs problèmes quotidiens de leur
angoisse devant le chômage et la vie
chère
comment rech plus dans ces conditions-là
abandonner la lutte mais j'ai eu aussi
des problèmes personnels et je veux les
évoqué par des milliers de tracts un
chauffage nationale on m'a dit femmes et
calomnié couverts de boue ma famille
elle-même n'a pas été épargné faux
résistants disait ton ou écrivez ton
hier mes camarades de lutte
prendre 20 compagnons de la libération
sont venus me rendre justice
faucon bâton marc en guerre 39-45 et
elle pas déjà un témoignage agents
d'étrangers complice des nazis candidat
qui voulait 10 et on rendre l'alsace
française à l'allemagne on a osé envoyer
de tels tracts en alsace française homme
de bonne de bruxelles
serai je ne sais c'en est assez pour un
seul homme on peut être patriote et
avoir des amis à l'étranger beaucoup
d'amis à l'étranger en aimant sa patrie
perry call francs-maçons tout à la fois
adversaires de l'école libre adversaires
de la laïcité
j'en passe mais serait ce un déshonneur
d'être catholique et tolérants envers
toutes les opinions en particulier bien
sûr celle des autres incapable médiocre
ridicule mais je m'honore d'avoir été
élu plusieurs fois président du
parlement européen par l'unanimité des
délégués français à strasbourg y compris
les voix de leader au tout ça c'est déjà
le passé et je remercie monsieur
pompidou d'avoir fière fait justice de
ces accusations et d'avoir tenu lui
aussi à ce que la campagne reste décente
je demande à mes amis je demande même à
mes adversaires de contredire toutes ces
propos diffamatoires qui croyais moi
sont indignes de cette campagne
électorale
en ce qui me concerne ma campagne à moi
restera ce qu'elle a été une campagne
d'idées une campagne politique et non
pas une campagne personnelle et je
développerai successivement tous les
thèmes que j'ouvrirais les douches et
que je dois ouvrir car vous avez à élire
un président de la république à choisir
entre pompidou ou poèmes pour libérer la
france du clan politique qui la domine
pour redresser son économie en péril
pour lui rendre ses libertés et défendre
la république pour que la vème
république celle de la constitution de
1958 soit la république de tous les
citoyens et de tous les français
vous me ferez confiance le 15 juin
prochain
merci mes chers compatriotes
[Musique]